Afghanistan is fighting on many
different fronts these days not just
with the militants but also against
human rights abuses and massive
corruption my guest this week here in
London is Abdullah Abdullah his
country's chief executive a role akin to
that of Prime Minister why is there so
much disunity in what is supposed to be
a unity government
[Music]
Abdullah Abdullah welcome to conflict
zone thank you
one of the things that western donors
didn't expect to be paying for in
Afghanistan was the frequent
mistreatment and torture of prisoners by
your police and security forces why is
this still going on there might be
problems this tent which I will not deny
it but the situation has improved big
deal at least since we are in the
government the national unity government
we have taken strong measures there was
there wasn't any education about it
prior to that there wasn't any any
awareness and laws were not were not
designed to deal with those issues but
it's there might be malpractice
somewhere but it is not like we have
been in a situation in this country
where which this was part of the
government program that's yes but you've
been promising for years to do something
about it and last year the UN assistance
mission to your country reported the
highest levels of torture in police
custody since 2010 so rather than taking
strong measures the situation seems to
be going back in Reverse getting worse
than it is absolutely not right it's not
but they don't know what they're talking
about the UN mission do you admission
what was the survey that they did in
2002 that now they are comparing it with
2017 on 16 the levels of torture have
we're seeing the highest levels since
2010 so 88 in the last eight years
highest levels the Kandahar Police was
said to be responsible for the torture
of 91% percent of detainees why do you
not investigate the Kandahar Police the
some of these things are worth looking
at and we are having a good level of
cooperation with the u nama which is
watching these things in there are other
organizations as well including civil
society which is an oversight over these
issues if if if I
it's not available with me today but I
can show you the report that the
improvement is being admitted and we are
having discussions at the highest level
the president in so you're at odds with
the UN assistance mission on this
because they decide to come if you if
you look at the company credible if you
look at the complete report they will
show you they will give you the results
of the reform which has been carried out
as a whole the improvement which is
there but whether there was that level
of access in 2010 or prior to that today
they have accessed everywhere and and
when they know the methods that you are
using which include forcibly pumping
water into detainees stomachs crushing
their testicles with clamps suffocating
them until they lose consciousness and
applying electric shocks to their
genitals are you proud of this and
nobody should be proud of this should it
be the case but what I'm gonna make it
up what Isis matter I can tell you the
in this feeling particularly that you
started your interview with there has
been a lot of improvement in the the
type of interactions between us you nama
in their human rights section is such
that they raise these issues with us
directly if we don't take action then
they will come back to us and yes we
need their support
we need them to bring cases to us but I
can assure you that certain strong
measures have been taken on the question
of strong measures like they weighed it
yourself with all respect you are
describing it that this is going on and
throughout the country in we are
oblivious to that and we don't pay any
attention to that that's last year you
talk about strong measures last year
according to Human Rights Watch you fail
to prosecute a single senior official
for torture is that how we're supposed
to understand your strong measures
against this practice you're talking
about the rule
long until do you prostituting not
securing people for torture do
procedures do procedures what is the
senior level that we are talking about
these are our details which has to be
seen and it has to be discussed the
Committee Against Torture last year
pointed the finger the Afghan National
Police Commander in Kandahar they said
he was widely suspected of complicity
and if not personal implication in
severe human rights abuses including
summary killings and the settlement of
secret detention centers has this been
investigated your subset suspected yes
if yes if anybody is and there are
widespread suspicions in the heaps on
propping up based on that report if
anybody was cited as being suspected do
you think that we have a system that we
can we can go through these suspicions
of everybody against anybody that's a
different issue
I said this is a key person in your
security forces this is a key figure in
your security does that not bother you
that his name keeps on cropping up in
human rights documents it does but I can
assure you that we are not learning
about the things through media we are
talking directly to the people
responsible into the authorities as well
and as well as the UN officials in Kabul
when they raise cases with evidence we
have taken it seriously
four months ago Human Rights Watch
called on you to investigate reports
that your Special Forces summarily
executed civilians in Kandahar province
during the period of January 31st to
February the 1st this year during
operations against the Taliban they
allegedly dragged some men from their
homes and shot them is this something
that you consider worth investigating
anything their search there have been
monitoring credible human Gessle
anything that such were your previous
reports all of them are worth looking at
but but to draw a picture that that's
the overall situation in our
country that's what I am but I am
challenging there have been other cases
also by our police or by our national
army or special forces but I can assure
you that have been investigated people
are imprisoned as a result of that
people have been prosecuted as a result
of that and that's that's that's the
reality so why does the Committee
Against Torture talk about a climate of
impunity in Afghanistan a general
climate of culture of impunity in
Afghanistan illustrated by the large
number of alleged human rights
violations involving senior state
officials this is from the UN Committee
Against Torture
the UN Committee Against Torture in
their representatives in Kabul you nama
we have very good level of cooperation
that's what I can assure you these are
serious crimes I think before here to
somebody in front of you listen to him
yeah I'm listening to you and our
audience will make it may will make
their judgement all my life I have
fought for the rights of people in human
rights and I have made sacrifices
personal sacrifices in millions of
people have made sacrifices in these are
not the things that we will take it
simply as such in January last year your
attorney general ordered nine guards
employed by first vice president Abdul
Rashid Dostum
to answer questions about the abduction
illegal imprisonment and sexual assault
on a rival politician Ahmed ishi
doston refused to allow his guards to be
called in instead they had to be
interviewed in his compound seven of
them were later convicted in absentia
and sentenced to five years by the end
of last year not a single one of them
was in jail that suggests that you do
not have the power or the political will
to enforce even the decisions of the
courts in your country doesn't it the
same case that you are referring to it
has another angle two to eight as well i
will not get into details of it but at
the same time you see that two
the first vice-president is not in the
country at the moment those people which
are which are suspected of of those
crimes they are not available to us
there are fugitives and if they if the
if the if we find them they will be
prosecuted the fact is that your legal
system is hopelessly compromises and
that Freedom House said earlier this
year that corruption among judges is
extensive with judges and lawyers often
threatened and bribed by local leaders
or militant groups they called it an
entrenched culture of impunity for the
country's political and military power
brokers in other words a situation where
the powerful can get away with whatever
they in every single report in every
single report but the you by the UN as
well as the relevant agencies you will
see approval of the reform which has
been carried out in the past few years
just just before bringing the forms in
an institution in your expecting results
it doesn't happen that way there has
been that culture embedded for many
years but you will see that you will see
that in every single report I put my
credibility with it the reform of the
judiciary sector the prosecutor general
general's office throughout their
country and also as a government we we
see it the result with the people in our
citizens which are approving in in
February on a visit to power one
province you admitted that the national
unity government had failed to fulfill
some of its commitments to the people
you said let's tell the truth to the
Afghan people and confess to our
inabilities and shortcomings I would
like to tell the people that we failed
to do for you what we hoped to do if
you've made a mess of it why doesn't the
government resign the point is that you
know it's it was said in the context
there are areas that European
shortcomings for example the elections
the parliamentary elections will be in a
few months time parliamentary industry
council elections this election should
have been held a year and a half back
that's a shortcoming that's a mistake
what about the human rights abuses and
the corruption in the country you
promise to do better the the nobody had
promised that Afghanistan will be
paradise as a result of two or three
years of the unity government but we
have promised to take steps to move to
make decisions which we have done the
those decisions are not just in vain it
has yielded results there has been
improvement and each if I if I if I say
that work is done in don't bother about
these things that's not my case that's
that not what I'm how is he flying come
is any of this helped by the political
squabbling going on between you and
President Ghani I mean that's at a time
when you're facing a national emergency
on so many fronts this is supposed did
you say to be a government of national
unity and you've been telling him he's
unfit for office how does this
squabbling help the country you're
referring to to a stated statement of
mine sometimes back which is 2016 which
I went into details of what I meant
about it but show me one single
government that there are no arguments
there are no debates there are no
discussions there are no differences you
said he didn't have the patience for any
discussion with you at that time why
does that make him unfit why did that
make him unfit you are the presidents
yourself had an opportunity to talk to
president irani and you have raised
questions which was related to him to
him directly now if there are questions
related to me I'm obliged to in respect
for your ideas to address it in address
them I would say that we came
as a result of a contested elections and
in order to save the country in order to
to prevent a complete destabilization of
the country unity government was formed
this is for the first time in our
history that two contested groups are
solving their differences through
formation of a common a joint set up but
your own MP Zach was criticizing you for
squabbling about identity guards in
placing a national emergency a crisis
where your very survival is in doubt in
peace of fighting each other over
identity in peace are there if there are
representatives of the people they
should criticize us we don't expect all
of them to be in agreement with me or
word president Ronnie that's normal
our citizens have the right to criticize
sense that I accept in your reference to
my statement in Parowan what we wish to
achieve we have not achieved it but but
that does not imply that that the unity
government has not achieved anything
Abdullah Abdullah is it any wonder that
the people Afghanistan have so little
faith in their politicians with all the
squabbling last November there were
opinion polls from the Asia Foundation
which showed that members of parliament
and ministers and the partners as a
whole received the lowest levels of
confidence from the people in the 30 to
36 percent range compared of course to
the religious leaders and even the press
which received almost double the levels
of confidence from people that the these
will be judged in it in a store amana
when their people go to the polling
stations in our focus in that's my
emphasis our focus has to be on credible
and credibility of elections the
upcoming parliamentary elections and the
district council elections and also
presidential cancer almost 40% of people
want to leave the country
no that sees that if they want to leave
they were saying party will be here it's
not that easy it's a considerable number
of being turned away by the European
Union if they manage to make
at the same time last year 700,000
people returned to their country compare
that with the number of people which are
living there before over 1 million
people returned back to the country and
and and they come as a choice yes of
course they are there there are
challenges coupled with that return of
refugees we haven't been able to make
them part of the development strategy
but we are supporting them we are
encouraged him in you're creating
enabling environment for them to rebuild
their lives
perhaps oh this look at two sides of the
story perhaps more would return if you
dealt or began to deal meaningfully with
corruption one of the biggest problems
that you face in Afghanistan in January
the US Special Inspector General for
Afghan reconstruction John Sopko put the
problem in context when he said while
President Ghani declared a national
jihad on corruption corruption is not
just a problem for the system of
governance in Afghanistan it is the
system of governments powerless to do
anything about this a lot has been done
a lot has been done in that respect and
with cigar John Sopko we have good level
of cooperation the he raises concerns in
certain areas about certain areas and we
take action about it and that's what
unfortunately we have inherited and
that's what what we have to deal in
address in it's our responsibility to do
it and have you taken I mean in 2011
your country was the second most corrupt
country in the world according to
Transparency International and now it's
the fourth so it's moved up just two
places in seven years is that taking
action that's not satisfactory but
that's that shows progress that's not
satisfactory at all that's not ideal far
from it but that shows progress all the
signs are developed that the security
situation is going to get worse this
year you spoke out last month about the
wave of recent attacks that
killed scores of people across the
country you don't have the troops to do
the job do you you don't have sufficient
troops to defend territory that you now
control or even take back territory that
you don't I'd be a few years back if
there were 150,000 international troops
in Afghanistan doing their job and they
had the combat role and now there are
15,000 there are 15,000 they don't have
the combat role their mission is to
Train support assist that was always the
mission no they were different combat
role earlier the combat role came to an
end and before 2040 but they were in
full combat role they were doing the
fighting and our Army National Army in
our beliefs has taken responsibility we
have high number of casualties as a
result of this and the conditions and
circumstances will not evolve according
to our wishes we will we will deal with
the circumstances with what we have but
this war is unwinnable 16 years of
intervention by the Americans and other
forces and the Taliban are still there
you offered them unconditional
recognition you offered them ceasefire
you offered them even an office in Kabul
why should why should they come and talk
to you when they've managed to survive
engagement with the most powerful army
in the world and are still they're still
fighting why should they talk to you if
they are citizens of this country in at
the same time they are being killed in
dozens sometimes and DD and daily basis
they are prepared to take the casualties
there is no doubt that they have taken
they have taken casualties but what they
have achieved they have an idea they
have an ideology they want to fight for
it politically the door is open for them
they want to kill innocent people that's
not nothing they will gain what a mass
of Afghanistan a few days ago called
upon as as the government as well as the
Taliban to observe ceasefire
our leadership our government accepted
that the same day that uh Lamaze were
holding that meeting there was a
suicidal attack these are the type of
groups which have been fighting in the
country and use terrorist methods they
are not unique to Afghanistan as well
but look at it from their point of view
they have survived 16 years why why come
to the table now they control almost 40
percent of your country can do million
can do in the world can you win the war
can you win the war is me important my
question is can they win the war in
another 16 years no they may well not
lose it you may the important thing is
you may not win it the point is that it
is our responsibility as the government
of Afghanistan first of all to do our
best to protect our citizens but the
situation is as it is unfortunately at
the same time to keep the door open for
toxic negotiations then I have no doubt
in my mind that that there will be
groups there will be people who will see
that this is an endless war and they
should give up violence in the door from
our side should be kept open it's not
just us it's not just Taliban it's where
they get support but the answer to you
opening the door has been a huge wave of
violence and so yet unfortunately yes so
you miscalculated by leaving the door
open you thought somebody would walk
through it sit down at the table and
negotiate with you they're not going to
it hasn't so far give me it give me one
example that the lost soldier killed and
then the war ended it has not happened
anywhere in the world
there is no cases classic or modern they
have shown their utter just a
responsibility towards the people then
towards the fate of the country they
continue to do so this will be very
unfortunate for us for the people of
Afghanistan but I'm sure that there will
be people who
think otherwise Wendy see their chances
and when the next presidential elections
come around again next year will you be
standing maybe standing again you said
in February it was time to tell the
truth to the Afghan people what
successes if you are going to stand what
successes can you point to which would
make people want to vote for you I
haven't decided yet
in also I haven't decided to start my
campaign while I'm here in London to say
what I will do for the people that but I
can promise that at any circumstances I
will be dedicated to the cause of our
people and well-being of our people at
under any circumstances there's still
well-being to be had among your people
will be you you have a population yeah
where 50 percent is under 15 yes
you have 3.5 million children who are
not going to school more than 85% of
them are girls
what kind of well-being do you offer as
millions of people millions of people
today under these difficult
circumstances younger generation young
and old boys and girls are rebuilding
their lives are contributing to the
well-being of themselves as well as the
country it's not that it's a you're
talking about a massacre
field and and and and people are pushed
into they do those those fields I'm
talking about people who can't have a
future 3.5 million kids unless they get
an education the unfortunately there
have been times that no single girl was
allowed education and our people have
gone through that as well like only two
decades back today still millions of
people arguing that these statistics it
helps us to focus on those areas but
percentages are all disputed yes in that
area that Taliban created insecurity
then they stopped people from going to
school the point is
that even in those videos and throughout
the country the main priority of the
people of Afghanistan first one will be
security the second one is education and
education for boys and girls and at the
same time that's where I say that
Taliban are already defeated their
ideals are rejected their ideology is
rejected the fact that the way of life
is rejected by the absolute majority of
the people of our parts it's a good push
I wonder if the people are going to buy
it if the people wouldn't buy it they
will not defend they will not send their
sons and daughters in the battlefield to
defend the system to protect the people
and to continue to be in the in in the
high moral ground offering peace and
defending the country abdullah abdullah
it's been a pleasure having you in
conflict so much thank you very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]